if I've been able to pull myself away
from my PC long enough to watch a movie
and do a video about it can only mean
one thing the servers for Diablo 3
haven't yet another problem so d let's
do a video the dictator the dictator
star Sacha Baron Cohen who's really
known for Borat and Bruno The Dude's
made for offending people from movies
that really play off of stereotypes
enter the movie The Dictator now before
Borat and Bruno were these mockumentary
type movies the dictators set up to be a
movie it's not like a mockumentary who
is a stereotypical terrorist type
dictator douchebag and you would think
that's the only stereotype he plays off
of but this movie really slanders a lot
of stereotypes which I personally like
I'm gonna be completely honest with you
guys stereotype humour works for me it
makes me laugh and in terms of things
that work in the movie The Dictator that
really works I just like knowing that
this movie offends really everybody
anyone can really watch this movie and
they'll be like oh that's really funny
because I'm not part of that stereotype
so now I'm laughing did another scene
will happen they'll be like hey that's
not funny it's almost like it's making
fun of me I just like knowing that
that's gonna happen with most people who
watch this movie they're gonna get
offended and they're gonna laugh and
it's gonna be a good time the movie
slanders everybody that is equality at
its finest the bummer is this movie does
the thing that I've seen quite a few
movies do and it never really works for
me the scenes are set up as isolated
jokes people enter the scene to set up
the joke the joke happens in the scene
goes to somewhere else it rinse and
repeat it makes every joke feel isolated
this movie does that it worked more for
this movie just because you know that
going in you know going into the movie
you're like it's gonna be like that
however I always hate seeing that it
never really makes a movie flow for me
but there are quite a few times in this
movie I was laughing my ass off I was
like that's funny then other times where
I was like I cannot believe they're
doing that but it's a Sacha Baron
Cohen movie did it surprise me not at
all if anything takes you by surprise
you really did sleep through or blink
through the first shot in this movie
people are gonna be like in the movies
rubber hands or ball it doesn't mean
it's a bad movie the movie is offences
but it set out to be offensive so in
that you can't say it being offensive as
a bad thing kind of like ever say a girl
looks but you don't mean she
looks ugly you just mean she looks
in fact she looks attractive she's hot
she just looks and if she dress
really skimpy to catch the male eye all
you're saying is you're sick
seating you what you set out to do and
it is not necessarily a bad thing just
like the dictator did it set out to be
an offensive movie yes or people calling
it an offensive movie yes is it a bad
thing no not necessarily just like the
chick you see what I mean oh you
know what I mean this feels like one of
those is a good time if you're drunk
type movies but there were quite a few
scenes that I was laughing in and I
can't laugh and all those scenes stone
silver and then be like oh yeah you'll
laugh if you're drunk cuz I wasn't drunk
and I was laughing that thing's really
the wow factor in this movie there's no
scene that I'm gonna remember months
down the line and be like that scene
yeah however the movie is good for some
laughs so I will say the dictator is a
good time no alcohol required if you
like movies like this so if you go see
this movie because I said is a good time
to alcohol required and you hate these
kind of movies and you hate it don't
come crying to me because you know what
you like and if you don't like Sasha
Baron Cohen movies you're not going to
like this movie so of the comedies that
are deemed offensive what's your
favorite one I'm interested to see now
what people consider offensive whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you